[Music]
[Applause]
mellow to hand jammed again taking it to
the rim
cheeping yard and behind see he knew he
had jetty right there
I'll seamless to fit has been to
Clemente and got to come over later this
out they got a four-on-three hood out to
mellow Jackson tooth has just always
been a gift them offensive player he's
got the last six maybe in June is 35
percent some three coming into tonight's
play dad goes water slipped on the floor
Gibson on a little change of pace and
laid it in so all done steel mellow
Bureau pops out to see Jake Isaac up and
down and then pinch the three the beasts
here attack
Anthony waiting pretty hands two-hand
Jam his ball goes up Scout he saw Bella
before he even jumped all I gotta do is
reach up there and get it to him get at
that direction
we have to make the plays and the last
just out of course
[Applause]
the stream LOL we to tell them like this
one and CJ with a rock dancing off
Lapierre pulls it out of the clutter
[Applause]
away from the scene where the three belt
loan REITs at a dome it never gets old
[Applause]
slams into
special who we got the full step let's
the help defense with cream clear out
take advantage
[Applause]
to getting a pant going to Turkey be
what they're dancing
journalist Noelle slaps it away Anthony
gets it back
Dixit back row Bader slithers by delayed
and that is a great foldable effort
there for the veteran that was a great
Wilson Carmelo right there even better
defense from Noel to come over and help
and see his to David be about there's
three people in the area and Melo comes
out with rejected by one side recovered
by CJ at the center of the court
[Music]
feeling
battle Anthony we're the triple beam of
credit to the speed
[Applause]
but goes to work on the screen they
switch it parking it out on him
[Applause]
where your help is all right beacons up
baseline and there's no help there
what's up you guys it's Taylor looks
with Abby to report make sure you
subscribe for more video content